Buongiorno signora Vuoi assaggiare Eh ma
questo è la nuvola massaggi vaniglia
Bourbon de Madagascar Amaretto di
Saronno e burro e sale rosa una
sciccheria se no possiamo scegliere un
pochino più a sud Abbiamo quello là che
c'ha una glassa di pistacchio di Bronte
scaldi di cioccolato di Modica e scorze
d'arance marinate 24 mesi non lo Zibibbo
Cioè glielo dico subito è più richiesti
quest'anno sono l'acetone che è un
panettone all'aceto balsamico abbiamo il
carbottone che è un panettone alla
carbonara e il Pasqualone che lei mi
darà Che cos'è Glielo dico subito è un
ibrido tra il panettone e la colomba Nel
senso che se poi li avanza È è se lo può
mangiare anche a Pasqua vuole un
panettone Ma certo che ce l'abbiamo
dipenda come lo vuole ce l'abbiamo il
caffè ristretto decaffeinato ginseng
Piazza Grande in vetro caldo Eh ma
classico come con uvetta senza canditi
con canditi senza uvetta con canditi
uvetta senza glutine e senza lattosio
con lattosio e glutine senza uvetta ma
con carditi Ah classico classico proprio
Basic banalissimo [ __ ] signora poteva
dirlo prima però eh Siamo stati qua
un'ora guardi che cosa che si è creata